[Music]  why is the whole job there are rumors  the legend outer sort of a king other  than yourself find him  I know your story what kind of a man  would you become had you inherited your  father's Kingdom instead of being raised  in a brothel poor gave you such Drive  [Music]  he found it didn't he  the power  it was Fortune who murdered your father  but what he didn't account for is what  you can do with this sword  we need to be careful his power is  increasing when people fear you it is  the most intoxicating sensation and land  can possess you start consuming  something you no longer miss  [Music]  I'm gonna kill her  funny bunny thing  [Music]  wanted to prophecy raise that floor so  the people the powerless caliber  you're playing with fire  but doesn't it make the palace burn well  you  there's the game  [Applause]